so at first when Fox News host Shepard
Smith would criticize Trump here or
there call out some obvious Trump lie it
was sort of a curiosity and it's now
happening in such a way that I'm
increasingly convinced that this is
actually part of a crafted strategy
around Shepard Smith I've got a clip for
you here where Shep Smith straight up
calls Donald Trump's hurricane hurricane
Dorian Sharpie Fiasco fake news to find
and we have to really understand this
for what it is but first let's look at
the clip remember this is on right-wing
Fox News some things in Trump LAN dia
are inexplicable this week's edition the
president's ongoing claim that Alabama
was at risk from Hurricane Dorian it
wasn't maybe he got some bad info from
somebody maybe he made a mistake maybe
he was confused we don't know but he was
wrong and since for days and days he's
been insisting with fake visual aids in
hand that he was right and then calling
it what it is fake news defined why
would the President of the United States
do this
he decries fake news that isn't and
disseminates fake news that is think
China pays the tariffs the wall is going
up historic inauguration crowds Russia
probe is a witch-hunt you need an ID to
buy cereal
noise from windmills causes cancer it's
endless and now the Sharpie map that
hurricanes Alabama a reporter asked him
about it he doesn't know but he won't
let it go yesterday he brought out
another map and a statement that reads
this was the originally projected path
of the hurricane in its early stages as
you can see almost all models predicted
it would go through Florida and hitting
Georgia and Alabama I accept the fake
news apologies this is where it one
where he can apologize and just move on
that map was from the day hurricane but
came a hurricane eight days ago August
the 28th it was four days old at the
precise time he said Alabama would
likely be hit harder than anticipated
and by then it was fake news defined on
a very serious subject this is
Shep Smith stepping out of line with a
disdain
against his bosses at FoxNews it's
abundantly clear that this is happening
with Fox News's executives approving at
least implicitly and I've been telling
you this for nearly two years at this
point I get emails from people how is
Shep getting away with this isn't Shep
potentially going to get fired we need
to reset our analysis of how corporate
media works Fox News wants to make money
above all else they've decided to do
this with right-wing editorial positions
in general they're not married to Trump
but they are right-wing but they also
benefit from having some ideological
cover especially when it seems that they
may break with the Trump train so what
you need to understand is that Shep
Smith provides ideological cover to Fox
News with safe calculated descent from
the everything Trump says is gospel
perspective which you see with Sean
Hannity and Jeanine Pirro and Laura
Ingraham and many others Shep Smith
isn't going to do anything that would
really damage fox news like for example
Shep's not going to call out the lack of
regulation that allows corporate media
outlets to become so big and
monopolistic and be so intertwined with
government and Internet service
providers and ultimately foment
narratives that don't challenge their
privileged status as legacy elite
corporate media he's never gonna do that
Trump will tell a thousand lies and
every once in a while Shep will call one
or two of them out for being lies it
will get some people on the left to
reconsider whether Fox News is as bad as
we think it is
it'll get some discussion about what's
going on on Fox News it will get some
right-wingers saying homophobic things
about Shepard Smith and calling for his
firing yes but the biggest thing that
this does is create some deniability for
Fox News to say look we don't always
carry water for Trump we don't always
defend everything a Republican does so
our analysis must account for the end
game in the short run at the micro-level
it's good to expose some trumpets
watching Fox to a tiny dose of reality
in the big picture Shep Smith on Fox
News
occasionally telling some
uncontroversial truth unconscious
to us that is is not going to change the
role that FoxNews in the corporate media
space plays and that's the analysis that
I've been making for a long time to the
extent that someone's echo chamber might
be pierced by Shep great maybe it'll
bring a little small electoral advantage
in 2020 if enough trumpets have their
echo chamber pierced by Shep Smith but
it does nothing to achieve the wholesale
reform goals and D corporatization and
des propagandas ation of corporate
profit driven media that we've been
talking about and it's really important
merely to acknowledge what's happening
with Shep for what it is and not go
beyond that because it simply doesn't
make sense and it's not actually borne
out by the facts